for embattled British Prime Minister
Theresa May this will be a weekend of
retooling after receiving the backing of
President Trump among other world
leaders May is filling out her minority
government and fighting for her
political life after a stunning upset in
Thursday's elections Jonathan Vigliotti
has the latest from London Jonathan good
morning good morning Alex with a nation
in transition the Prime Minister had
hoped holding an early election which
strengthened the UK instead she
fractured it with no easy fix in sight
Prime Minister Theresa May and her
Conservative Party were supposed to
cruise to victory but in the wake of
failure last night she snuck out the
back door of number 10 it was her far
left opponent from the Labour Party
Jeremy Corbyn who was supposed to be
crushed but his support was strong
enough to steal the Conservative Party's
majority status in Parliament I have
just been to see her Majesty the Queen a
weekend Theresa May went to the palace
to tell the Queen she could only now try
to govern with the help of a small
fringe party from Northern Ireland the
group's anti-gay anti-abortion beliefs
will make them complicated but necessary
allies if May is to lead the UK through
brexit negotiations May called for this
week's snap vote three years early
hoping to increase her party's majority
and strengthen her hand ahead of the
divorce from the European Union strong
and stable strong and stable strong and
stable leadership her campaign seemed
anything but strong and stable after a
series of rushed policy u-turns it's a
mess the European Union is closely
monitoring if not already capitalizing
on German Chancellor Angela Merkel
speaking from Mexico said brexit
negotiations would not pause to let the
UK deal with housekeeping ones via we
will of course wait for the results of
the British elections she said but the
meetings with Great Britain will start
in the next few days and with any
divorce the brexit essentially boils
down to money and with the Parliament as
it stands today divided Anthony
negotiations are going to be tough
Jonathan Vigliotti in London thanks
Jonathan